foreign
if you want to build a good habit
roughly speaking there are four things
that you can do you want to make it
obvious you want to make it attractive
you want to make it easy and you want to
make it satisfying so obvious attractive
easy satisfying now if you're sitting
there and you're thinking how can I get
myself to meditate more you can just
turn those into questions and you can
say how can I make the behavior more
obvious how can I make it more
attractive how can I make it easier how
can I make it more satisfying and you'll
start to notice different things that
you could do so for example how can I
make meditation more obvious well do you
have a clear space where you're going to
do this you know like maybe you need a
meditation pillow and it's in the corner
of your bedroom or it's in the corner of
some other room that is the dedicated
meditation space and this is exactly
where it happens so it's obvious where
the behavior is going to occur make it
attractive there are many different
types of meditation and there are a lot
of ways to get into it and this is true
for any habit by the way for some reason
I think we often choose habits that we
feel like we should do but it's not
necessarily the one that we want to do
individually and there's you know there
may not necessarily be a thousand ways
to do everything in life but there's
almost always more than one way and you
should choose the version that you're
most genuinely excited about you know
that is most appealing and interesting
to you because if you're genuinely
interested in it then even like there's
gonna be all kinds of ways to improve
you'll find all sorts of things that you
could like refine or make it better but
if you're not actually interested if
you're like not genuinely engaged in the
task even the obvious stuff is going to
feel like a hassle you know it's going
to feel like a chore even if it's
straightforward so
do you want a guided meditation maybe
it'd be nice to have somebody kind of
walk you through it or do you want to
find a meditation that has like lovely
music associated with it do you not want
anything do you just want silence and
you want to be able to like hear
yourself think for a minute or listen to
your own breath for five minutes and
that's kind of the objective but what
sounds most attractive and appealing to
you try to find a version of The Habit
that you're actually interested in
this actually I think connects to the
timing piece that you were talking about
Tim which is yeah in the morning is a
great time for a lot of people but if
you have young kids and like your
four-year-old is running around you're
trying to figure out how to get pants on
them and you need to make you know
breakfast like that's probably not a
good time to do it you know so like find
a time and a space where that habit can
live where it's attractive and you're
not just going to end up frustrated
because you're trying to like swim
upstream make it easy so rather than
doing 15 or 20 minutes or 30 minutes of
meditation which hey that sounds great
because your favorite Guru does it but
listen like why not just do 60 seconds
because if you can Master the art of
showing up if you can just do it for a
minute and actually stick to that day in
and day out then you're starting to
build the habit and now you have
something you've like gained a foothold
and you can advance to the next level
one of the the things I recommend in the
book is called the two minute Rule and
it says just take whatever habit you're
trying to build and you scale it down to
someone takes two minutes or less to do
so read 30 books year becomes read one
page or meditate you know
five days a week for 30 minutes becomes
meditate for 60 seconds and you're just
trying to master the art of showing up
you know like a habit must be
established before it can be be improved
it's got to become like the standard
before you worry about optimizing it
into some perfect thing so make it easy
to do make it easy to show up and then
the final thing is make it satisfying
now if you've done those first three
steps well it's obvious it's an
attractive version of it it's pretty
easy to do you're probably going to feel
pretty good about yourself because
you're at the end of The Meditation
session now so like that'll probably be
pretty satisfying but you can layer on
some kind of additional benefit you know
maybe you get to have your favorite type
of coffee or your favorite drink after
that or maybe you get to have
a bubble bath or a walk in the woods or
whatever sounds motivating to you you
know so find some way to to add some
additional positive emotions to the
experience because if you feel good
about it you're going to want to repeat
it and this is something that in atomic
habits I call it the cardinal rule of
behavior change which is
behaviors that get rewarded get repeated
and behaviors that get punished get
avoided and it's so basic it's so
obvious but all humans want to feel good
you know we all want to have positive
emotions to be supported to be loved to
be rewarded to have something that feels
good and so how can you get that feeling
and Associate it with your habits that's
kind of the the core idea and ultimately
this connects back to what we talked
about with identity which is the perfect
version is when you perform a habit and
you feel good because it's reinforcing
your desired identity you know I'm the
type of person who wants to meditate
each day or I'm the type of person who
doesn't miss meditation sessions and
then even if it's only 60 seconds you
can feel good about doing it because
it's reinforcing your desired identity
so that's kind of a quick case study on
how to apply the ideas